August 1992 spearfisherman David Gant
and Scott Williams returned to Nicky
Jack to get the one that got away we was
going back looking for the big fish we
just been finding that not know one day
the cave is a labyrinth thousands of
feet long
after an hour they called it quits
as we was a send in my hand touch rock
and we shined their lights affair and it
was a solid rock roof we knew there was
underwater caverns there but we kind of
thought we knew where they were
somewhere they made a wrong turn at that
point we painted and we started swimming
together and were breathing fast I
emotion to Scott that I was going to go
find our way out and I left Scott on the
bottom looking at his compass
up on top I came back down to him and he
was gone there was suddenly by myself
didn't have any idea of which direction
to go
Just Breathe and uncontrolled will be
fast scared to death David is now
hopelessly lost he's deep inside the
cave and running low on hair I was
thinking to myself what was it gonna be
like to take that last breath the hair
and pull in that first mouthful of water
what was it gonna be like to drink Scott
finds the entrance just as he runs out
of air when he gets to dry land he calls
911 is still lost after 20 minutes he
emerges in a small cavern I was just
very very happy that I found an air
pocket I mean that was really happy I
found an air pocket it's now midnight
david has no way of knowing whether
Scott has managed to raise the alarm
he can't rely on a rescue I tried to
leave that air pocket can make some
short circles you know hoping that I
could find my way back but it was all in
vain
at 4:00 in the morning
a police dive team enters the cave they
believe David's heir must be exhausted
they're looking for a corpse
I knew that somebody was in there
looking for me and I gave me great hope
remember pulling out my dive knife and
pulled my hand behind my back and
tapping my taint because you can hear a
lot further underwater
so I started tapping on my tank you know
real hard
wonder I didn't bust a hole in my tank I
tapped only so much at night but I never
there never didn't get close enough to
me I could see their lights or that I
could really tell that they was getting
close it was all in the distance
the divers dare go no further for a
systematic search they need a map they
contact veteran cavers Dennis Currie and
buddy Lane the map shows air pockets in
the cave this still gave us hope
immediately that that you know David can
be found alive in there my philosophy is
until someone or that we're looking for
is cold dead and stiff in front of me
they're still potentially alive and
we're gonna do what we can to recover
those people